whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners up New York
City whose Health Department wanted to
slash the number of establishments that
sell booze but after public outrage
erupted Medlin Mike said that this is
one kind of nanny even he doesn't
support I was a smoker for 26 years and
for the last 14 months I've been using
electronic cigarettes to successfully
quit and the Indianapolis City Council
for trying to ban electronic aka fake
cigarettes from public places it's water
vapor but there can be only one nannies
a month and this time it's LA mayor
Antonio Villaraigosa who signed a
first-of-its-kind law requiring porn
actors to wear condoms while performing
I have Ono on wearing condoms at horn
right but no mayor or law can change the
minds of customers who want condom free
performances and although fighting
infection is a noble goal over the past
decade there have been only six cases of
HIV among American porn actors so what
will happen producers in the
multi-billion dollar industry may simply
leave LA and if crackdowns become more
severe more porn may go overseas or
underground where safety oversight would
likely be worse check back next month
for more examples of busybodies minding
your own business
you